yo what up space fam goals in here from
anime upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest crazy and i mean
crazy updates in the one piece story we
got more on shanks
info about a god figure a truly epic
fight and more
so make sure to stay tuned for this one
if you do enjoy these one-piece reviews
and want to keep them coming the best
thing you could do
is channel the pirate king within and
smash that like button until it's as
blue as the grand line itself and
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss out on future one piece videos
which includes reviews and also a bunch
of different topics and
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop feel free to check out my growing
one piece playlist that includes videos
on all the supernova
warlords yonko and much more link to
that
is in the description now without
further ado let's jump into it spoilers
and
all so this chapter is called jinbe vs
who's who
and that is a hype title in and of
itself jinbe is a powerhouse that should
not be slept on and i'm so glad we get
to see him in action fighting for the
straw hats i also think the cover art is
pretty adorable here with page one
reading a book about dinosaurs with ulti
pestering him
to play with dinosaur plushies never
thought i'd see so much
dinosaur stuff happening in one panel
and i love it
so we start up the chapter emphasizing
tama's accomplishment in turning a total
of 3 000 headliners with gifter powers
to the straw hat side they're
predictable happens and they come up
with the idea of killing tama in order
to stop the weird power that's affecting
their gifters usopp holding tama and
running
is understandably freaking out as all
eyes are on them while daifugo
the scorpion smile user comes in to help
it's such a heartwarming scene
seeing tama light up as she sees him and
he gives her a thumbs up it's a small
moment but even amid
all the epic crazy fights and reveals
going on i really appreciate
oda adding these little moments in the
weirdly hot
speed aka horcella comes to the rescue
and they hop
on as usopp is forgotten in the back
screaming
let me on too you can bet sanji would
have a similar reaction
but for different reasons we also
received news that komachiyo is going to
be fine
and looked after which means a lot to
tama another thing she doesn't have to
worry about
nami i'm now exhausted usab draped on
speed's back
comment on the insane power of thomas
fruit which allows her to turn
enemies to friends in a moment i really
enjoy how creative you can get with
devil fruit powers and tom has a prime
example of that oda has done a great job
making it so that they can be used in
very creative and strategic ways
and then we have another heartwarming
moment and one of my favorites in the
chapter honestly
zeus musters up the courage to ask nami
if he can be her servant again
and nami says no way i think all of our
hearts broke for a second there
before they melted as nami said we can
be partners instead and winked
i much like zeus love nami all the more
after hearing this
and this was such a great moment for
showcasing her character
and then as a bonus zeus is newly
motivated and starts yelling out of the
way
nami's partner coming through as he
electrifies the opponents in his path
so so sweet i mean it's not sweet for
the people being horribly electrocuted
but it is for us the people who matter
and then we get even more amazing news
not only are headliners switching a lot
of their subordinates followed in switch
sides too
we're told that this resulted in 2 000
additional traders for now we then jump
to cp 0 who are nice enough to keep
score for us
we're told that now the go board looks
completely different as it's currently
16
000 beast pirates versus 9 000 straw hat
forces
during chapter 1003 we were told that
this thing
started with pretty much over 30 000
beast powered forces
and 5 400 enemy infiltrators our guys
were almost
outnumbered 6 to 1 by this count 5.56 to
1 to be specific
but now they are outnumbered by less
than two to one
1.7821 to be specific these odds are
insanely better and it shows just how
much progress we've been making it's
undeniable that things look
much better than they did before despite
luffy's loss against
kaido and now our side has momentum too
which is a big deal
even cp0 mentions that the gifter's help
could result in white's continued
success
and on their go board the white pieces
represent the straw hat forces i
still love this go metaphor and still
love how it's showing us
how the straw hats are making the
impossible happen little by little so if
they finally do end up in the lead or
even winning
it will be believable cp0 lets us know
that they in
fact are not concerned with the result
they just want to confirm
his death his ends up meaning who's
whose and even though his
insider info is dated and he probably
can't harm the world government now it's
the principle of the matter and they
can't allow
a rogue escapee to live because it would
set a bad precedent
i really enjoy these conversations and
it goes to show that the world
government thinks several moves ahead
yeah who's who
himself might be harmless but if people
start questioning the
world government's reputation then it
may lead to more significant problems
down the line
that being said they should probably be
going after luffy after everything he's
done
but for whatever reason they are simply
after who's who this time
and they guessed that he probably won't
survive because after all he's facing
jinbei gotta love that jinbe respect and
i absolutely love moments like these
where outsiders praise members of our
crew
drop a hashtag jinbei hype in the chat
if you agree
who's who is no joke and his own people
know they gotta get out of there because
he's getting serious
this fight is where we get a lot more
interesting info building on the
previous chapters
insane reveals we have it confirmed here
that red-haired shanks by which he
probably means the red hair pirates
stole the gomu gomu fruit from him which
is how he ended up in prison
last chapter we weren't sure if shanks
actually stole it himself or got it
later but i said it would be hype if he
thought the fruit was important enough
to attack a marine vessel that's no
small thing to do
and that extremely hyped scenario did
end up being true
again it seems to suggest that the gomu
gomu fruit is very important if shanks
was willing to significantly agitate the
marines for it from what we've seen
shanks is not one that starts conflicts
willy-nilly so this
is truly a special case questions arise
like
is the fruit tied to joy boy in some way
in a prophecy is that why in addition to
other reasons
shanks was willing to sacrifice his arm
to save luffy since he was possibly
saving the fruit or
joyboy or the prophesized one in the
process
nothing is for certain but man i
absolutely love these tidbits of
information that can shed a completely
different light on the very foundation
of the story
all the way back to the first chapter in
the meantime who's who
is launching fang pistols like a madman
as
jinbei's insane armament haki lets him
take it like the most stoic of men
who's who states that luffy wears the
same hat as shanks and he gained the
power of the fruit so it's only natural
for his resentment to spread from shanks
to him as well and it makes sense
yeah logically luffy isn't really to
blame here but logic doesn't matter much
when it comes to emotions luffy is a
constant reminder to who's who
about how he was wronged and how his
promising life was stolen from him it
doesn't surprise me at all that he'd
direct his frustrations on luffy
even if it's not justified logically but
back to the fight itself
jinbe did manage to dodge the majority
of attacks and who's who says
it was the right move because even with
armament haki
jinbe would have been eaten alive he
delivers quite the backhanded compliment
when he says and i quote i didn't think
a slimy fisherman could move that fast
on dry land and quote hardcore prejudice
in that statement
you know the word slimy is not an
acceptable term to use with fishman and
neither is generalizing about all
fishermen as who's who likes to do it
nonetheless is noteworthy that jinbe is
so fast on land while he'd also
completely wreck who's who
in the water a huge flex on his part
however
jimbei is less focused on the speed
complement than he is at who's whose
discriminatory views
of fishman saying he's not sure what to
say to that
since it is no longer generally
acceptable to express such views who's
who keeps giving us more reasons to
relish in his eventual defeat
not that he needed to who's who sort of
apologizes by laughing it off
and saying my bad and even that is more
than i expected to get from him in a
battle between
pirates i do find it interesting how
they keep the conversation going as they
battle
with who's who straight up saying he
wanted to ask something
before rushing in to attack jinbei with
his armament hockey cloaked fangs
but jinbei's haki overpowers him and
sends who's who
flying back bloodied then jinbei really
goes to town and we love to see it he
launches
water bullets and who's who admits that
it hurts
but he asks the very interesting
question nonetheless he says when he was
in prison he heard a story
and he was mockingly told to pray to a
certain someone for salvation he
continues and i quote
apparently slaves in ancient times
believed in a legendary warrior that
would eventually come and save them
they called him sun god nika it was said
he would bring laughter to their lips
and free them from their suffering
who knows if he really existed though
end quote we also get a silhouette and
you probably won't fail to notice that
it has
quite the rubber-like characteristics
obviously
it could be explained away by saying
it's an oversimplified caricature of an
unknown person
but this shadow could also be
foreshadowing who this sun god nika
actually
is there are huge parallels to joy boy
here and thus luffy as well
who has been connected to joy boy in the
past just recently by kaido
it said that this sun god figure would
bring laughter and
end suffering sounds like a joy boy to
me for now what i think this is
are cultural variations on the same
stories or myths kind of like
neptune versus poseidon furthermore what
i like doing when i get new names is
looking up their meanings and
associations because names are often
significant and shown in series for one
reason or another
according to wiki which i
unapologetically use as a source all the
time
nika can be a slavic name that comes
from the greek goddess of victory
nikkei or we might recognize this as
nike the popular brand
in persian it means very good or pure
crystal water
both sound like luffy who in my view is
destined for victory
and has also often been portrayed as
pure
in certain senses like his lack of lust
in general for instance
and in particular his insane lack of
lust for the very attractive boa hancock
it can also mean
good true and chosen all things at this
point we could definitely associate with
luffy
in one way or another luffy has in many
ways been set up as the chosen one
in one language it also means little and
was used as a nickname for the youngest
boy in the family
another fact that applies to luffy who
was the little brother
of sabo and ace again nothing is certain
but i think we're given
a lot of reasons here to associate joy
boy and the sun god
and luffy together luffy already freed a
bunch of people and i have no doubt he
will free more
before this is all through his goal has
always centered around freedom after all
let me know your thoughts on all of this
in the comments
is there a chance that luffy is the sun
god in your view
anyways back to the fight and talk where
who's who
says he clung to that story during his
long prison stay because he wanted to be
saved
not something you expect to hear from a
tough villain or antagonist
again jinbe is like bro stop talking
this has nothing to do with me but then
who's who says that jinbe led the sun
pirates
a crew made up of former slaves and even
generalizes the history of all fishmen
to be a history of slavery he delivers
an onslaught of attacks and jinbe
seems to use full body armament haki
here
from the outside looking in it looks to
people like who's who
is winning like the flying six members
are way stronger than former warlords
who's who keeps talking too relentlessly
mirroring his own physical attacks
saying the guard that who told him about
the sun god vanished a few days later
without a trace
and he figured since he knew the story
he was in danger too so he risked his
life to try to break out and he clearly
succeeded
and then we get an insanely painful
looking scene where
jinbe's haki is so strong who's whose
finger breaks and honestly that panel
looks more painful than 99
of the injuries i've seen in shonen
jinbe then turns the tide pun intended
and says he has nothing to say to him as
he kicks who's who's butt
he prepares to launch an ultimate
technique which are always hype
who's who is wondering why he's so mad
all of a sudden and jinbei tells him
that it's because of the broad ignorant
statements he was making about his
entire people's history as he launches a
gargoyle tile fist that appears to ko
who's who to his men's horror jinbe
looks grim indeed in the final panel
and yeah he pretty much just kicked
discrimination's butt
right in front of our eyes this was
definitely a fitting fight for jimbei
and it was necessary to give us more of
a taste of his insane power the cp zero
agents were right to assume that with
jimbei here
who's who would probably end up dead and
we definitely can't be certain of him
actually being dead but he definitely is
an easy target now if the agents want to
finish him off the fight was great in
and of itself and jinbei
is definitely my mvp for this chapter
let me know who yours is in the comments
although i'm guessing it's probably
jinbei too
however the most interesting thing was
probably the information about the sun
god nika
and what that'll mean moving forward and
its connection to
already existing legends prophecies and
characters in the world of one piece let
me know what you think about all of this
since i will definitely be cruising
through the comments to read your
theories for the sun god
it's a super hype detail that i can't
wait to learn more about
and that is it for this one what an epic
chapter we had
jinbe greatness more shanks and the oh
so intriguing mystery of the sun god i
cannot wait for the next chapter but a
heads up it looks like one piece will be
on break next week if you do enjoy these
chapter reviews though and want to keep
them coming you know what to do
smash that like button with no mercy
until it's blue if you haven't make this
the video you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss out on
future one piece reviews and other
related videos
and while you wait for the next chapter
to come out in hopefully two weeks feel
free to check out my growing one-piece
playlist that includes videos on all the
yonko
warlords supernova and much more link to
that is in the description
also leave suggestions for one piece
video ideas that you are burning up to
see in the comments
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon
here on youtube who helped make videos
like this one possible first and
foremost i want to thank the patron of
legend the one acknowledged by lord
tuigo himself alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans ingrata but
they have the algatal dr cortman the
toasted chi
the spike emperor otaku spidey life
tinel tungsten tarkis big buddhist cody
hebert and monkey d
quilly and our pro hero tier patrons the
one and only gilgamesh the red haired
raven angel cruz anatoly kazatsuki very
gucci alicia actor bonnie parks hinokami
and water joey and garcia ted no 10 fat
boy games cory mcgohan metal mama deadly
saint and soul ride slice and dice thank
you all
so much if you do enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime upper and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about manga chapters anime life and
of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com link
in the description
if you're interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to subscribe
button that you've hopefully already
destroyed a lot of you guys have been
doing that which i love to see so yeah
you can definitely support that way as
well
and whichever way to support us you will
get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
you